yeah vegan a drink no would someone be
sensitive like what is the potato and
did is it I don't know how you know they
like as a coarse herb is this dehydrate
it was to origin of it I don't know
there's a lot of wine that's not vegan
apparently yeah is that what they do egg
whites yeah I don't even really to be
honest I don't even really know what the
[ __ ] a real vegan is animal products
what is the what is what is it what
engines can't right we should well if
you are claiming to be a vegan vegan
diet a vegan diet is give a [ __ ] about
vegan for the health of it or for
actually what is doing animals and she
both oh for sure really yeah so you can
you share how chickens are slaughtered
and [ __ ] it's a reason yeah to be honest
with you bro I just you know I just hit
you with this right here the reality how
I feel no animal needs to die for me to
live okay my son turned 14 this year
never had a piece of meat in his life
okay go do eight pull-ups right now okay
my oldest son haven't had meat in his
life he could bench over 200 pounds okay
six to eight pack play good guitar piano
great memory he never had no hot dogs
never had a hot dog listen house 21 21
he never listen okay if he had a hot dog
was a vegan hot dog not a will grandma
house or nothing now the whiskey no
point being made to you right blow is
that I'm only saying that to say that I
got I could look at my household
a living example that you don't need I
wish you dad to live a man I'm not
arguing whatever because I'm especially
so now I talk [ __ ] about vegans and [ __ ]
I talk about [ __ ] about plant-based
[ __ ] but I know now like what
the way people cook it and um the more
options there's more options to eat like
that then it was when I was coming when
I was coming up it was just like that
sunrise paddy that's the only big until
you eats of broccoli or carrots or
something but it wasn't no option and it
wasn't so many people doing it with you
you wouldn't find a no vegan restaurant
you like it would be one spot you got
away go away over here you go to Jamaica
spot in Brooklyn
if you was a vegetarian you had that one
steam pot in there the mixed vegetables
that's only thing he was gonna get
didn't have no meaning yeah I was
invited I became vegetarian so made ODB
yeah you get those you're Tito's man
what I got to do what I got to do I
could like and plus I ain't really see
my son that much what I got to do I
could do it anytime tomorrow I'm gonna
see somebody I could be near four hours
later I need to get some time my son I'm
chilling here so I know I ain't get
invited but hey you're here so sorry did
you when did you stop eating meat how
many years has been I haven't had a
piece of red meat since 1995 Wow and
what about fish and I've had a piece of
poetry since 1996 I can finish the
liquid sword album I guess and I haven't
had fish I stopped being fish son in
1997 yeah I feel Everage my father feel
good if you go hold on to fish yeah
kool-aid you like a glass no no no yeah
I had a good weekend okay so I just take
the weekdays and congratulations thank
you
expect that sir I respect this yeah I
got you know I'll get to it I like to
make
I'm not drink but you know if I give I
have a heavy weekend I got it take some
yak some cheese so what do you do you
monitor your nutrition and make sure you
get all your bases covered your amino
acids and your proteins and all you like
how do you mostly the whole food diet or
the supplement I don't I don't really
monitor yo all right I don't eat a lot
personally you know I marry like on a
good on a good day for my best the best
versa
I'm not eating once a day anyway once a
day yeah like what's with the typical
man have it you ever eat today
really no you know me I got some I got
so many letters I got some lettuce wraps
yo you give them that [ __ ] you try to
give me son that I want to eat after I
might finish this what's the yo why you
act like I'm against being a vegan oh
well I never said I wouldn't love it's
your diet man only thing I'm saying is
you know I don't know Allah no f-bombs
you would eat one of those right what's
this
the wheezed right butter no no it's nut
butter you can't leave it with not you
can't leave it with healthy oils nuts
cool crunched-up nuts guys I crunched up
nuts all right yeah a lot of those it
makes a liquid that some people some
people are cool with a liquid diet I'm
just a couple with it tastes good and
the veggies need nutrition work real
quick okay it's great [ __ ] man well I
like this reading it it sounds very
healthy it's as basically just protein
in them organic dark chocolate bother
man why you keep because everything you
only don't say this to you because I
won't go to him it's not working all
right but every time you say something
you said it like before you start
tripping out I'm not good you gentlemen
but alright this is for you okay
no no it has dark chocolate in it okay
so dark chocolate is known to reduce
high blood pressure right us as black
men we're you know they say we have high
blood pressure right basically based
laws been in America not getting that
real natural Sun breath and having a
high sodium diet understand blood
pressures dark chocolate helps reduce it
so this is good for me yeah it's good
for everybody but why you got just
directed at me like I need dark
chocolate you know what I'm just next no
no I'm just saying she pointed be a [ __ ]
I'm sorry I like dark chocolate like
everybody else like dark you like no
chocolate with dark John I like dark
chocolate
[Applause]